très bien je vous raconter une histoire
c'est une histoire vraie à la fois
quelque chose qui m'est arrivé mais
aussi quelque chose que j'ai fait et je
suis sûr qu'à un moment donné dans ce
récit vous y retrouverez la dernière
j'étais en italie pour faire un erasmus
à padoue une ville étudiante près de
venise et comme la météo donné assez
clémente et le ciel complètement dégagé
on a décidé avec un groupe d'amis de
faire un tour en montagne nous étions un
groupe assez sportif par ces sportifs
j'entends encore un jogging tous les
toutes les deux semaines
alors notre idée était de faire un peu
de course à pied dans les montagnes pour
voir à quoi pouvait bien ressembler le
fameux massif des dolomites
alors on a mis un short et des baskets
en a pris le premier train du samedi
matin vers bassano del grappa une très
jolie ville sur la bordure des alpes
nous avons commencé à courir au pied de
la montagne en suivant le chemin de
randonnée du monte grappa
mais très vite on s'est rendu compte que
la pente était tellement abrupte que
continuer à courir donné presque
impossible alors on s'est vite résolue à
marcher tout le monde la matinée les
paysages que nous pouvions n'irait était
vraiment sensationnel vraiment
magnifique
après une pause déjeuner nous avons
décidé de continuer à marcher sur le
même chemin mais on a mieux aucune in et
l'altitude à laquelle on pouvait bien
être ou la distance déjà parcouru mais
on a continué à marcher et quelques
heures plus tard on a commencé à
rencontrer la neige là c'est devenu plus
compliqué parce que à chaque pas qu'on
pouvait faire nos puits sans fonds c'est
dans 20 centimètres de neige alors on a
commencé à se demander si c'était
vraiment une bonne idée de continuer à
marcher mais après un moment on a divisé
le groupe et j'ai voulu continuer avec
ceux qui n'en avait pas marre de croupe
de voir des panoramas de plus en plus
impressionnant alors on a continué à
marcher à fatiguer bien marché et au
bout d'un moment comme le soleil baissé
on peut voir le sommet du monte grappa
qui avec les ans nous semblait plus qu'à
quelques kilomètres
alors bien sûr on a décidé l'atteindre
et après une bonne dose de marché un peu
même un peu d' escalade nous arrivions
au sommet du monte grappa et de là-haut
vue imprenable sur l'autre versant de la
montagne la chaîne des alpes à nos pieds
à très très bon moment ensuite nous
avons lui faire une petite pause au
refuge du sommet pour manger un jeu trop
de l'apparemment nous n'étions plus très
loin l'autriche et là on a commencé à
s'inquiéter pour le tour cette fois nous
avons décidé de prendre la route de
montagne
il a dévalé en courant oui il a dévalé
parce que quand on a commencé la
descente on pouvait voir le coucher de
soleil puis du soleil et finalement
c'était la nuit on ne s'est presque pas
arrêté de marcher de courir pardon et
pour cause le dernier train pour padoue
pour rentrer chez nous partez deux
heures plus tard en courant je voyais
régulièrement le même panneau avec un
numéro inscrit
sans une telle mesure j'ai compris ou
d'un moment qu'il s'agissait d'une bande
chromée tricks et je ne me souviens plus
combien en avoir vu mais plus de 10 et
certains ou n'a peut-être deux heures de
course
on s'est arrêté sur un balcon qui
surplombe et toute la ville de bassano
et ses lumières
là on a compris qu'on n'aurait pas notre
train mais peu importe on a continué à
courir est une des rares voitures qui
passaient par cette route de montagne
quasiment déserte et dans la nuit nous
prenez tous les quatre en auto-stop
sauver et quelques minutes plus tard on
s'écroulait sur littéralement sur les
sièges de la garde
le lendemain matin alors que je pouvais
à peine marcher avec mes jambes tout
courbatures et j'ai aussi un message de
georg l'ami allemand qui avait eu l'idée
de faire ce jogging dans les montagnes
il avait retracé sur un site internet
le parcours que nous avions fait pour
voir la distance parcourue et nous
avions marché et couru pendant 38 km est
monté puis descendu 1600 m de dénivelé à
ce moment là j'étais en train de me dire
mais j'ai quasiment fait un marathon et
hier et pas à paris dans les alpes
je ne vous aurais vraiment pas cru si
deux jours plus tôt vous m'avez dit que
je ferais une telle chose et c'est sûr
parce que pendant cette journée ne
savions pas vraiment ce que nous
faisions nous avons réalisé ce que l'on
faisait pendant en le faisant
en réalité et nous n'étions pas
mentalement préparés à cela
ah oui personne dans le train n'avait
idée que nous ferions une marche aussi
longue et en montant ne savions pas
jusqu'où on pourrait aller et même hors
des cent ans on ignore alors en nous
disant que peu importe on saurait
coiffeur en arrivant en bas et je pense
sincèrement que cela nous était
bénéfique vraiment chaud nous savions
vraiment ce que nous faisions et nous
savions que finalement la fin serait
finalement bonne mais c'est ça à la fois
l'ignorance nous apporter beaucoup de
choses et finalement savoir ce que l'on
fait n'est peut-être pas une très très
bonne idée finalement parce que vous
êtes ici dans cette salle il ya des
entrepreneurs il y à des étudiants qui
veulent innover qui veulent créer qui
veulent faire des choses et développer
des choses mais quand ils se demandent
quand il atteint il est un draw leur but
quand ils finiront leur projet ils se
découragent et ils ont quoi se
décourager parce que la route est longue
et fastidieuse et qu'ils en voient pas
la fin mais heureusement elle est
ponctuée de très beaux moments des
moments qui nous pousse à aller plus
loin et à continuer de marcher et c'est
ça parfois cherché à savoir ce que nous
faisons où nous en sommes et ce qui nous
reste à faire n'est peut-être pas une
bonne idée peut-être faut-il dans
certains cas ne pas savoir ce que l'on
fait pour les plus loin et elle est plus
haut
peut-être faut-il juste continuer à
marcher
merci beaucoup